?
>> OKAY, SO HE WAS THE HEAD OF
THE JUST APARTMENT ACTIVELY
WHEN THIS IS GOING ON.
>> PAUL, ALI, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
>> THERE'S SOME MAJOR NEW
DEVELOPMENTS IN RUSSIA'S WAR IN
UKRAINE.
THE UKRAINIAN COUNTER OFFENSIVE
IS NOW UNDERWAY.
FOUR VILLAGES ALREADY TAKEN
BACK FROM RUSSIAN CONTROL IN
THE SOUTH.
THE KREMLIN IS ACKNOWLEDGING
UKRAINE'S COUNTEROFFENSIVE BOOK
CLAIMS THAT IT FAILED
MISERABLY.
THAT STATEMENT, OF COURSE,
SUSPECT IS SO MUCH FROM THE
KREMLIN.
IS JOINING US NOW RETIRED U.S.
ARMY LIEUTENANT COLONEL
ALEXANDER VINDMAN, THE FORMER
DIRECTOR OF EUROPEAN AFFAIRS
FOR THE NATIONAL SECURITY
COUNCIL.
AND YOU ACTUALLY JUST RETURNED,
ALEX, FROM UKRAINE.
WHERE YOU ARE HELPING THE ARMED
FORCES AND TALKING TO A NUMBER
OF OFFICIALS THERE.
JUST WALK US THROUGH HERE WHAT
WE ARE SEEING AND THIS FOCUS ON
THE SOUTH.
>> THANKS.
I'M ACTUALLY LITTLE SURPRISED
THAT YOU'RE LETTING ME --
>> YOU SEEM TO KNOW HOW TO DO.
THIS ANALOGY GO-AHEAD HERE.
>> I BASICALLY ACHE CAME IN
FROM POLAND INTO KYIV AND SPENT
SOME TIME DOWN IN THE CENTRAL
PARTS OF UKRAINE.
IT'S KIND OF AMAZING TO
UNDERSTAND THAT THIS IS
HUNDREDS OF HUNDREDS OF
KILOMETERS HERE.
RIGHT NOW, WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
THIS AREA IN THE SOUTH.
IN KHERSON.
IT'S ABOUT, ALMOST 100,000
KILOMETERS FROM HERE ALL THE
WAY TO THE BORDER.
ONE OF THE THINGS I WAS WORKING
ON WAS GETTING ALL OF THIS
EQUIPMENT FIXED BECAUSE IT'S
IMPOSSIBLE TO SUSTAIN A WAR
EFFORT FROM THAT FAR AWAY FROM
WHERE THE --
THIS RIGHT HERE IS THE --
RIVER.
IF THEY DO MANAGE TO DO THIS,
THEY HAVE THE RUSSIANS BACK TO
THE SOUTH.
AND THEY'LL BE ABLE TO FOCUS --
THE FORCES THAT ARE HERE WILL
SHIFT TO THE SOUTH IN THE EAST
TO START TO LIBERATE OTHER
PARTS OF THE COUNTRY.
IT'S A HARD FIGHT, A LARGE
AMOUNT OF TERRITORY AND FRANKLY,
I'VE GOT SOME CONCERNS ABOUT
WHETHER THE UKRAINIANS HAVE THE
COMBAT POWER TO DO.
IT'S ONE OF THE THINGS I
LEARNED WHEN I WAS IN UKRAINE
IS THAT THEY'VE TAKEN AN
ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF LOSSES,
ABOUT 30 TO 40% OF THEIR
COMPANY GREAT OFFICERS, YOU
LIEUTENANTS AND CAPTAINS, THOSE
THE ONES DOING THE FIGHTING
RIGHT NOW.
BUT IF THEY DO, THAT EASES THE
STRATEGIC --
FOR THEM SIGNIFICANTLY.
FRANKLY, YOU CAN SEE A BROADER
COLLAPSE IN THE RUSSIAN ABILITY
TO KENTUCKY THIS --
>> WHAT DOES IT TAKE TO PUSH
FROM HERE TO THE RIVER?
AND TAKE US THROUGH A LITTLE
BIT MORE THAN, WE CAN LOOK AT
THE DONBAS, TWO OF WHERE THAT
COULD LEAD THE UKRAINIAN
COUNTER OFFENSIVE IF THEY ARE
SUCCESSFUL.
>> SO I DESCRIBE THIS IS
PROBABLY THE LAST MAJOR
OPPORTUNITY FOR A SHORTER WAR.
IF THE UKRAINIANS ARE ABLE TO
DO THIS IT WILL DECISIVELY
SHIFTED OR SHOULD HAVE OVERTIME
UKRAINIAN SIDE.
IT WILL PROBABLY BREAK THE
MORAL SPIRIT OF THE RUSSIANS
AND LARGE PORTIONS.
THEY'LL HAVE TO ASK THEMSELVES
SOME SIGNIFICANT QUESTIONS.
KHERSON RIGHT HERE IS THE MAJOR
CITY THAT THEY'VE MANAGED TO
SEIZE.
BIGGER THAN MARIO POLL, THAN
ANYTHING ELSE.
IT'S STRATEGIC.
IT ALSO GIVES THEM CONTROL A
BIT IN A PRO RIVER.
IF THEY MANAGE TO DO, THAT YOU
CAN SEE THE REPOSITIONING OF
FORCES.
ALL THE WAY FROM BACK IN HERE
TO THIS FRONT OVER HERE.
SOMETHING FAR MORE --
PALATABLE UNMANAGEABLE FOR THE
UKRAINIANS TO START TO, FIRST
DEFEND AND THEN ATTACK THE RIM.
>> WHAT DOES THIS DO TO THE
TIMELINE?
THIS IS LOOKING SO MUCH LIKE A
GRIND.
HOW LONG DOES THIS GO ON?
FOR >> I THINK THE UKRAINIANS
ARE THINKING ABOUT DOING THIS
OVER THE COURSE OF THE REST OF
THE SUMMER, INTO THE FALL
BEFORE THERE'S A WINTER FREEZE.
THAT WINTER FREEZE DOESN'T MEAN
THE END OF FIGHTING.
BUT WHAT IT DOES MEAN IS
PROBABLY A SIGNIFICANT
REDUCTION.
IT'LL JUST BE HARDER FOR TROOPS
TO CONDUCT OPERATIONS,
EQUIPMENT STARTS TO BREAK DOWN.
AND THEN YOU CAN SEE A FIGHTING
SEASON REEMERGE IN THE SPRING
AND SUMMER NEXT YEAR.
SO THAT'S WHAT HAPPENS IF THE
UKRAINIANS DON'T GET HEARSE ON,
DON'T LIBERATE KHERSON.
IF THEY DO, THEN I THINK RUSSIA
IS IN A VERY DIFFICULT
SITUATION.
IT'S GOING TO HAVE TO START TO
THINK ABOUT, SERIOUSLY CONSIDER
--
NEGOTIATIONS AN EXIT --
AND AN EXIT TO THE.
WAR >> POSSIBLE NEGOTIATIONS.
LET'S GO BACK TO THE BIG
PICTURE.
HOW MUCH --E B
HOW MUCH LAND COULD UKRAINE
REGAIN WITH THE RESOURCES THAT
YOU SAY IT NEEDS?
>> I THINK KHERSON IS VIABLE.
AGAIN, IT'S THIS AREA HERE.
THAT'S PROBABLY SOMETHING THEY
COULD REGAIN IN THE NEAR TERM
OVER THE COURSE OF THE NEXT
SEVERAL MONTHS.
I THINK THE REST OF IT, IF THEY
HAVE CATASTROPHIC SUCCESS, IT'S
AN INTERESTING TERM.
MORE THAN THEY EXPECTED, THEY
CAN START TO MAKE GAINS IN THIS
DIRECTION.
ZAPORIZHZHIA.
AND TO REALLY JEOPARDIZE
RUSSIA'S LAND BRIDGE TO CRIMEA.
I THINK THE REST OF THIS AREA
OVER HERE IS GOING TO HAVE TO
WAIT UNTIL SOME OTHER POINT IN
TIME.
THAT'S THE AREA THAT THE
RUSSIANS H